Hello friends welcome to 3abn today
Bible q a we're so glad that you've
joined us you know you're part of our
three ABN family and it's always special
to spend this one hour with you today's
program is a journey through the Bible
based off of questions that you
submitted to us here I was talking to
our producer Ladonna earlier this week
and she says every time this program is
aired we get a lot of questions in here
two three abns so we're so grateful for
your interest in the word of God and
today I'm surrounded here on the set by
I'm going to call you guys all pastors
of the word of God you're all teachers
of the word of God evangelists of the
word of God brother John denzi so good
to have you here with us today it's a
blessing and a joy to be here and it's
wonderful to study God's word and to see
that people are interested you know what
the Bible says true very encouraging
isn't it when you think about this day
and age that we live in there's a lot of
things going on a lot of chaos but we
can find answers in the word of God
sitting next to you his brother Daniel
parents so good to have you here sir
thank you very much it's a blessing to
be a part of this amen and I know you
taught Bible for 18 years or so an
academy before you came to 3abn but I
know even young people have an interest
in the Bible right absolutely lots of
questions being generated and as you
teach you learn yeah you know that's
very true and sitting next to you
evangelist may I call you that Ryan day
so good to have you here it's a blessing
to be here love Bible q a and thank you
all for submitting your questions
because it helps us to learn and to dig
deeper and to get answers to even
questions that maybe we haven't even
considered before so thank you yes a
very thought-provoking questions that
are submitted So yeah thank you again
and I want to encourage you to submit
your questions or comments For an
upcoming program you can do it several
ways you can do it through email and get
my glasses on here so I get this right
it's Bible QA at 3abn.tv bibleqa at
3abn.tv you can also grab your cell
phone and text us your question that
number is
618-228-3975 you can also do it through
Instagram Instagram we get a few of
those that is 3abn underscore official
3abn under score official you know today
as I when I woke up I was thinking about
a song that I grew up with it's often
thought about as a child song but to me
it's applicable to all ages in the
entire world and that is Jesus loves me
this I know for the Bible tells me so
tells you so amen you know what does
Jesus
mean to you think about that for a
minute what is Jesus Christ mean to you
you know we're studying the course the
word of God today finding answers in
God's word but what does he mean to you
personally is he your friend your savior
your Redeemer before I can just hear you
now answering out loud what does Jesus
mean to you but gentlemen here on the
set what does Jesus mean to you Pastor
Johnny
that's a very profound question it can
be you know you look at that and you say
well first of all he is my savior and I
think of him as a friend it's good and
comforter and I mean there are so many I
can keep on going and going because the
reality is Jesus is everything to me
amen yeah how about you Daniel uh you
know this was talked about in the
devotional I read this morning with my
family thinking about the fact that
every day we Face Temptations and trials
and things that are bigger than our
strength and so to know that Jesus
promises that he's he is there by your
side immediate that you have help that
is above and beyond what you need to
face whatever you're going through I
appreciate having Jesus with me amen
amen you know without Jesus there is no
hope he's my eternal hope
um I am you know the Bible makes it very
clear in John 15 that with without him
we can do nothing and that also means
that we are nothing without him and so
he's my all he's my everything he's my
he's my rock he's my Fortress he's
Divine and I'm the branch and without
that vine that Branch doesn't exist
praise the Lord for Jesus right amen
before we open the word of God and go to
some questions Pastor Johnny just pray
let's go to the Lord in prayer
our wonderful and loving Heavenly Father
we come before your throne of grace to
ask
for the blessing we need of your Holy
Spirit
we ask that you will use us to bring
Bible answers to these Bible questions
we thank you for three at the end that
you have raised up and these last days
of Earth's history to proclaim a message
that is needed in the world
and we pray for your blessing upon all
those that listen to this program that
your holy spirit will guide them as well
and help them to understand the holy
scriptures we pray for a blessing upon
all for we ask it in the holy and
blessed name of Jesus amen amen and amen
all right let's go to the first question
and brother Johnny let's start with you
this comes from Ghana
via email and it's from isaka
what does the bible teach about rings
specifically rings for the finger or the
one which is commonly used to
differentiate between married and
unmarried groups
indeed that is a good question and uh
isaka or isaka I'm not sure how you
pronounce it but thank you for sending
in the question the Bible does not
mention the use of wedding rings it is
not found there the Bible does use the
word ring first time it is found it's in
the book of Genesis when the Pharaoh
gives his ring to Joseph
this doesn't mean that we're getting
married it means that because of the
leadership he saw in Joseph and the way
he answered the dream and interpreted
the dream he saw in him leadership
quality gave him the ring so that he had
authority to make decisions in Egypt and
he was second in command and Rings were
used to put seals on documents
mainly and the fact that you had the
king's ring was a very high honor but
when we look at the Bible
since we don't find it used in weddings
where did it come from
it actually came from the Egyptians the
Egyptians used rings and Genesis points
out points that out eventually as you as
history developed other cultures began
to use Rings now the ring
they have uh and excavations found Rings
where it's a circle with a serpent like
biting its tail trying to say that
there's a cycle of life and psycho and
life continues it's like a symbol of
Eternity yeah those this is the way
people look at it eventually Rings began
to be used for weddings and this is
outside the Bible Jewish people did not
originally use rings in weddings this
evolved and as a matter of fact when the
Romans were the Greeks and ideas kept
going from culture to culture the Romans
started using and the the uh the the
poor poorer classes did not wear metal
rings they wore rings made out of reeds
and even hemp but those that were of
higher class
they would use Metals such as gold and
silver and it was mainly used by Kings
eventually it became became used in
weddings in summary you can say that the
use of wedding band is not a Biblical
practice it is really a cultural
practice practice it is not even a legal
requirement anywhere in the world it is
an optional requirement but people look
at this as a symbol oh that person is
waiting wearing a ring he is married she
is married but then you get confused
because people have rings on all the
fingers so how do you look at this is it
a Biblical practice no we cannot say
that it is it is a cultural practice in
fact there are some cultures that if you
are married and you do not wear a
wedding ring it is a shame as if you're
trying to hide that you are married
so
but in most cultures it is not looked
upon that way in the U.S it is taken
more as of a common practice that oh
that person is married wearing a ring
wedding ring today doesn't make a
difference people don't care if you wear
one or not they will try to entice you
to sin so it's an optional go to the
Lord in prayer and ask him what he would
have you to do all right thank you
brother Johnny uh
Daniel this one comes from Jacqueline
and she lives in Indiana this is her
question during creation was it implied
that Sabbath should be observed or was
it written somewhere during that time if
implied does First Corinthians 4 6 have
significance and is Sabbath and Eden the
same as the one given to the Israelites
and us today good question all right
thank you Jacqueline for your question
and uh it's a good one let's start out
by reading First Corinthians chapter 4
verse 6 which says now these things
Brethren Paul writing here I have
figuratively transferred to myself and
Apollos for your sakes that you may
learn in us not to think beyond what is
written that none of you may be puffed
up on behalf of one against another so
in the context of what Paul is writing
here he is saying that we need to not
idolize a human preacher or speaker or
leader but instead go to the word of God
and verify by what we believe what we
know to be true based upon his word so
we establish what we believe from
scripture so what was written to Adam
and Eve well nothing was written nothing
needed to be written down their memories
were absolutely perfect and so when Adam
and Eve were given life they knew
nothing everything that was to come into
their mind through their experience or
through what they were taught by God
God's truth is revealed to us we don't
make it up on our own so God taught them
about who he is God taught them about
his holy law that had been broken in
Heaven by Lucifer God taught them about
the preceding five days of creation and
who was it that taught Adam and Eve that
the seventh day was blessed well that
was God himself in their very presence
who as it says in Genesis 2 3 God
blessed the seventh day and Sanctified
it and he told them where he explained
to them why now God's blessing upon the
seventh day wasn't just a personal
notation for his own record keeping just
to notate to himself that he was
finished with his work it was a
pronouncement it was a declaration made
to the people that he gave it to God
didn't need to bless a day just for
himself to rest and Adam and Eve had not
even experienced a full day so there had
not yet been six days of Labor uh before
this first day of rest and so what God
is doing he could have created in a
moment but he chose this pattern of six
days of Labor followed by a day of rest
to set a pattern for all the people to
follow how they should live their lives
and this is why Jesus says there in Mark
2 27 that the Sabbath was made for man
and not man for the Sabbath this was a
blessing to continue
so following Paul's instructions there
in First Corinthians 4 what was written
it was the entire books of Moses Genesis
through Deuteronomy they don't exist in
isolation so what do we find written
there Exodus 20 verse 8 to 11 makes it
abundantly clear to us that it is
written that we should remember the
Sabbath day to keep it holy because six
days God labor did all his work and
therefore on the seventh day he rested
and Sanctified it staying there in the
book of Exodus what was written chapter
31 verse 16 and 17 says that the Sabbath
is a Perpetual sign a Perpetual Covenant
and a sign to last forever and in
chapter 16 when God provides Manna it's
very clear through his instructions that
he sets the Sabbath day apart as special
and they understood that and they knew
it so that the Sabbath was something
that when he says to remember it that
he's reminding them to remember what had
already been blessed by him one more
thing here God communicates his life
and by example we look to Genesis
Chapter 4 verses 10 and 11 the voice of
your brother's blood cries out to me
from the ground God's speaking here so
now you are cursed from the earth which
has opened its mouth to receive your
brother's blood from your hand how could
God not respect Cain's offering or how
could God hold him accountable for
murder if he had not revealed his law
already and so this reveals to us that
just because it had not been yet written
down in the brief account of history
from Genesis chapter 1 to chapter 3 that
it still was God's command that was
explained and understood and when God
blesses it's not just for the moment He
blesses the animals He blesses man
Genesis chapter 1 verse 20 and 28 to
continue and the same is of the Sabbath
and God never changed that the same day
given to us amen wow yeah praise the
Lord good question and great answer
brother Ryan this comes from Jamaica all
right I'm here is Wilson
is it okay to pray while burning incense
lighting candles or even using anointing
olive oil for the sick why don't
Adventists do it yet it's biblical all
right so thank you Wilson appreciate the
uh the submission it was a great
question uh you know my my initial
response you know or the initial thought
when I saw this question was you know
where in the Bible do we see God
directly commanding or telling us to do
these things when we pray now do we do
we see these things in scripture yes do
we see candles being lit uh obviously in
the Jewish culture yes even still today
many people are like Sabbath candles or
they're like candles you know for
ceremonial purposes we do see the
burning of incense there in the practice
of the sanctuary especially within the
altar of incense itself these things
were representative of something and but
of course within the practice of the
sanctuary this was for ceremonial and
ritual purposes in which those were
temporary and that Jesus Christ would
fulfill when he would come by the by his
blood they're shedding those blood so in
this case my friends I just want to
speak on this you know we need to make
sure we're balanced on this in these
type of things and make sure we
understand and ask the question why why
are we doing this why am I you know
burning incense when I pray why am I
lighting candles is this somehow making
my prayer more reachable to God does it
somehow enhance the the uh the
communicable ability to God because I am
burning this incense and this smoke is
filling the room or rising up or the
candle lit somehow uh you know gets
God's attention a little better at the
end of the day you know we see there in
Matthew chapter 6 or you know in other
parts of scripture the disciples are
actually asking him the Lord teach us
how to pray and there we see you know
Jesus gives the model prayer in Matthew
6. what does he say you know when you
pray burn incense light candles and
break out the olive oil because you're
gonna need it is that what he says no he
says when you pray pray like this and of
course he delivers us that model prayer
my friends at the end of the day we have
to understand that that the Bible does
not give us any direct command God never
says you know what I need you to burn
incense When you pray to me it it you
know it helps it just I receive a sweet
Aroma and it just helps me to receive
your prayers better or I need you to
light a candle because you know I need
to be able to see you while you're
praying or whatever the case may be
these type of things are simply not
requirements for God hearing your prayer
or you speaking to the Lord some people
do this for spiritualistic reasons
there's a lot of paganistic practices a
lot of cultic practices that do this for
some very extra spiritual reasons that
are actually have satanic undertones and
we have to be careful that we're not
delving into something of the occult and
in under the banner of of reaching
Christ or speaking to Christ that it's
not the case now speaking of olive oil
we do have a direct text on this James
chapter 5 verse 14 says If anyone among
you is sick let him call for the Elders
of the church and let him pray over him
anointing him with oil in the name of
the Lord so that is we have a direct of
text on that one and it does encourage
us that in the cases where someone is
really sick they are to call on the
elders and they can indeed use that
olive oil not that the olive oil itself
has the healing properties or some kind
of Miracle making abilities but yet it's
a symbol of the holy spirit it's a
symbol of of of healing it's a symbol of
restoration that God wants to do to
someone so we're encouraged to do that
based on its meaning and I just wanted
to provide those texts and just make
that very clear you don't have to burn
incense and you don't have to light
candles just simply wherever you are
call out on the name of the Lord and He
will hear you yeah fantastic that's
beautiful great answer
this brother Johnny comes from we've had
several people actually ask this
question one is uh Madge from Maryland
and Carol from Oklahoma and it has to do
with the seven last plagues Revelation
18 8 mentions plagues coming in one day
is this based on a prophetic day for a
year principle referred to in Ezekiel 4
6 how long will the plagues last
that's a good question
um
some people consider this that it will
take one year that is prophetic time but
really the construction there in the
Greek it really implies suddenness
and a time of uh immediate that it will
happen suddenly and and the duration is
unclear it is a symbolic uh phrase here
let's go ahead and look at this uh
notice that Revelation 18 let's begin
verse 4. and I heard another voice from
Heaven saying come out of her my people
lest you share in her sins unless you
receive of her plagues for her sins have
reached to heaven and God has remembered
her iniquities so he's talking about the
amount of sins here and now and notice
here rendered to her just as she
rendered to you and repay her double
according to her works in the cup which
she has mixed mix double for her so in
other words God is going to punish
according to the works according to the
amount of sin so is it worth one year of
sin God knows exactly how much this is
going to happen but notice in verse 7.
in the measure that she glorified
herself
and lived luxuriously in the same
measure give her torment and sorrow for
she says in her heart notice I sit as a
queen and am no Widow and will not see
sorrow there's a type of boasting taking
place here but notice a verse 8
therefore her plagues will come in one
day you know suddenly she's staying home
I'm enjoying life I'm sitting as a queen
but suddenly in one day the day death
and sorrow mourning and famine and she
will be utterly burned with fire for
strong is the Lord God who judges her in
other words God is saying your day is
coming your time is coming for you to be
punished according to your Works will it
last a year we do not know it won't last
today that's for sure because she's
going to be punished according to her
works so here the uh in one day and Mia
MRI which is a symbolic symbolical term
for suddenness just like it says as you
continue reading that it says for
example in one hour it says here as you
continue reading in Revelation chapter
18 10 it says in one hour for example it
says standing at a distance for fear of
her torment saying alas alas the great
City Babylon that Mighty City in one
hour your judgment has come soon is
suddenly the time is coming the hour has
come verse 17 it says for in one hour
such great riches came to nothing every
ship master all who travel by ship
Sailors and as many as trade on the sea
stood at a distance and again in verse
19 it says again in one hour so does it
mean in one hour it's all over it means
that the outcomes the day comes when the
punishment will take place how long it
will last it's according to her sins
amen yeah thank you so much Pastor
Johnny you're very good and the great
questions too coming in this one comes
all the way brother Daniel from Bulgaria
okay from vesi
how can we understand such strong malice
towards the enemy and some of the Psalms
like Psalm 69 Psalm 83 and Psalm 109. it
doesn't sound christ-like okay uh good
question and uh it is the Psalms you
mentioned are just some of the most
notable of Psalms that we we might say
contain curses and for those who like a
bigger world word some people call them
imprecatory Psalms and the first thing
to understand is that these are prayers
that we're actually speaking these words
and those who wrote them those who
prayed these are praying them in God's
presence to him if if I were to speak
words like this to an enemy that those
would be an experience of violence
toward them in words like this shared
with a third party it is just spreading
stories and spreading anger and Malice
but when I pray this to prayer and you
can't do anything other than to be
honest with God you can't hide your feet
healings you can't hide your your
expressive response to what's evil
around you but when you express it to
God you're placing Justice and Vengeance
in the hands of who it belongs with and
that's God so we should be aroused by
evil when we see and experience sin we
should have a natural response but how
we deal with that is what's important
here and so this is these prayers are
not for personal revenge or for
selfishness really it's saying Lord we
want to put all all the the response to
evil in your hands and listen what Paul
says here in Romans 12 19 says beloved
do not avenge yourself but rather give
place to God's Wrath for it is written
vengeance is mine I will repay says the
Lord and so this is a plea for God's
intervention and then as we put those
feelings into God's hands we allow him
to change our hearts and ultimately we
say with the psalmist search me and try
me and then we can see that God begins
to give us the compassion when needed
that he has and so we see how David who
wrote some of these Psalms how he
responded to an enemy think of how he
dealt with Saul or ish boshette or Abner
or or Absalom or shimmyi in each one he
dealt with compassion because God was
changing his heart
and so as we're uh we're praying these
prayers it's really a prayer for divine
Justice in the great controversy
Ephesians 6 lets us know verse 12 that
we are not wrestling against flesh and
blood whatever enemy we might see out
there there's a spiritual battle and
when we pray this prayer these types of
prayers were saying Lord I want your
Justice to to be seen ultimately we want
these prayers to be true because we want
evil not to prosper and these prayers
are rooted back in in Deuteronomy
chapter 28 where through inspiration
Moses declares that there are blessings
for obedience and curses for
Disobedience and we say Lord we want sin
to be dealt with each one of these
Psalms that you read are are individual
they're different and you study each one
of them individually and you recognize
that there is a that each one of them is
is revealing something about how we then
put our lives in God's hands and we let
him deal with evil hmm amen wow yeah
thank you so much for that question
thank you for the answer from the word
of God
brother Ryan this comes from uh doesn't
give a name but from Ohio all right if
we were going if we are going to be
changed in the twinkling of an eye why
couldn't we go straight to heaven when
we die
all right all right thank you so much
for whoever submitted this question
um you know I just want to say run off
um you know being changed in the
twinkling of an eye and going straight
to heaven when we die are not synonymous
with each other it's a very very plainly
clear clearly stated in First
Corinthians chapter 15. so we're going
to go there first Corinthians chapter 15
is where we find this these words you
know changed in the twinkling of an eye
it says they're beginning in verse 51.
this is First Corinthians chapter 15.
and we're going to read verse 51 to 54.
it says behold I tell you a mystery we
shall not all sleep but we shall all be
changed and the question is when when
will we be changed well Paul tells us
when he says in a moment in the
twinkling of an eye at the last trumpet
for the trumpet will sound and the dead
will be raised that's Resurrection the
dead will be raised incorruptable and we
shall be changed so notice the
resurrection and the changing happens
synonymously but yet we do not see this
concept of being changed at the point of
death there's no text in all the Bible
so to directly answer your question you
know why can't we go straight to heaven
if we're changing the moment we can open
eye because the Bible says that we don't
and the Bible makes it very clear
otherwise if we continue on with that
text in verse 53 it says for this
Incorruptible must put on incorruption
and this Mortal must put on immortality
what change is ultimately taking place
you know according to Philippians you
know our vile bodies are being changed
and made likened to his glorious body we
are putting on immortality because
that's the change that's occurring but
that only happens at the resurrection at
the second coming of Jesus not at the
point of death verse 54 goes on to say
so when this corruption must put on
incorruption and this Mortal has put on
in mortality then shall be brought to
pass the saying that is written death is
swallowed up in Victory so notice death
is not dealt with until the end till the
resurrection until the second coming
when we are changed when we put on this
immortal reality and you know what it
you know this idea that we are
immediately changed or we are
transformed or taken directly into the
very presence of God at the point of
death just completely undermines the
Resurrection the hope of Resurrection uh
because the fact that we die and we
sleep in the grave you know
metaphorically obviously we're not
literally taking a nap or sleeping but
we are completely unconscious unaware
the spirit the breath of life has been
taken from us it goes back to God we
cease to exist as a living human being
until God returns that breath to that
body and resurrects us so the the
resurrection or or the sleeping in the
grave or the unconsciousness in the
grave necessitates and brings about the
requirement for the resurrection which
is Our Hope first Thessalonians chapter
4 verse 16 what does it say for the Lord
himself will descend from heaven with a
shout this is talking about the second
coming it says with the voice of an
archangel with the trumpet of God that
we see a trumpet in First Corinthians 15
yes so remember in a moment at the last
Trump right here it says and the dead in
Christ will rise first so when will that
change happen at the resurrection at the
end of time not at the point of death
wow amen boy praise the Lord looking
forward to that time yes
brother Johnny this comes this question
from Sam that was sent in via email
how old is the world exactly
and if this world was given 6 000 years
then how far are we from the coming of
Christ
thank you so much Sam my middle name is
Samuel so we're we're kind of uh alike
in that area I want to say something
concerning the other question because I
don't want to give a wrong impression
and talked about the ring and the circle
and the serpent biting his tail they
believe this was a cycle of life and
that life continued that's not what the
Bible teaches the Bible teaches you die
and then you wait the resurrection of
the just or the resurrection of
damnation so I want to make that clear
that's good clarification now let's go
back to this question is uh how old is
the world exactly and if this world was
given six thousand years how far are we
from the coming of Christ good question
no one really is able to tell you
exactly how old the world is we can come
to an approximate time and uh the reason
we can come to an approximate time is
because the Bible gives us genealogies
and the Bible also mentions some things
concerning the Life of Christ that maybe
you can come to a a year when this took
place for example in Luke chapter 3
verse 1 and 2 says now in the 15th year
of the reign of Tiberia Caesar Pontius
Pilate being governor of Judea and Herod
being tetrack of Galilee and his brother
Philip tetrakov ituria and of the region
of trachonitis and lycenius and tetrack
of Abilene Anderson Kaif as being high
priest the word of God came unto John
the son of Zacharias and the Wilderness
this helps us arrive at a somewhat of a
date but when the creation takes place
this is the problem the first individual
to calculate and make public a an
approximate time for creation was Bishop
James Usher in the year 1654 using the
genealogies of the Bible he came up with
a day that the Earth was created around
4004 BC
uh and this was so so well uh accepted
that uh in the Bible's beginning around
170 1701 they began to put these dates
in the Bible uh when things took place
and so this is how we get the idea that
we're close to 6 000 years uh because
you calculate the earthquake about four
thousand Jesus Christ came about uh two
thousand years ago so we're close to the
six thousand years but we don't know
exactly when that will end and that is
the problem other people have tried to
find this approximate time they're
individuals there was a monk called bead
that suggested that it was
3952 BC that the Earth was created uh
Sir Isaac Newton also had a tried to
find out and he suggested 4 000 BC
that's when the Earth was created so
there's this little discrepancy about
the creation of the earth when it took
place and we don't exactly know the year
exactly now some people have tried to be
specific and they said it was in October
at about 12 noon when the Earth was
created I don't know how they come to
that I don't know we have to be careful
with these things what we need to do is
be ready for the second coming of Jesus
Christ every single day that's right so
that's I'll leave it at that for now
amen thank you so very much brother
Johnny let's go to you Daniel this comes
from Trinidad and Tobago from Lena and
the question is how do I begin to study
the Bible or question it is and I'm glad
you asked it sometimes people are afraid
to ask a question where they think oh
everybody else already knows all this
but never be afraid to ask a question of
something you need to know so from your
question you're beginning with first
steps and you have to start somewhere so
I want to take you to Revelation chapter
1 verse 3 and I think there's a good
pattern to follow here said blessed is
He who reads and those who hear the
words of this prophecy and keep those
things which are written in it for the
time is near so it starts out blessed
are those who read so making that simple
commitment and that decision I'm going
to read these words and to do it
regularly which means daily not just
once in a while and to do that you have
to carve out some time a best to do it
in the morning but some people do it at
other times of the day as well and
there's a time and a place to have
conversation with people but you carve
out some time that is is just for you
and God to sit and take in these words
and if somebody's talking and you can't
hear them very well sometimes you'll cup
your ear like this to eliminate
distractions so I would say eliminate
some of the distractions and use one of
these right here a paper Bible because
this never brings up a pop-up ad no text
comes to me except for the one that God
sends and there's no battery issues
I don't have to wait for this to load so
take that Bible and actually read it and
then as as Jesus quotes here from
Deuteronomy 8 verse 3 he says man lives
by every word that proceeds from the
mouth of God so commit yourself even if
it takes time to read all of God's word
and where to start let God help you
decide on that many people like the
gospels that clearly tell us what Jesus
is like now blessed are those who hear
the words this means to consider to
contemplate to attend to and understand
this invites you to think God wants you
to be a thinking person Isaiah 1 verse
18 God invites you come now let us
reason together think about it this
would be the digesting we don't want to
eat food and not digest it and so
contemplate and as you do ask God to
keep his promise to give you the Holy
Spirit every time you come to the Bible
sit down in prayer kneel down in prayer
John 16 13 says that when the spirit of
truth comes he will guide you into all
truth claim that promise and then
blessed are are those who keep the
things written in it here's a commitment
that we must make the Bible is not just
a book of knowledge and information but
it is life-changing it is God's very
words written to you and to say Lord
whatever it is that I understand even if
I don't understand it all I'm going to
be obedient by your grace and your
strength make that commitment to do that
now as you read of course there are
things that you might not understand God
says that his word gives light to the
simple it gives gives understanding to
Anyone who reads it so ask for God's
help write your questions down and don't
be afraid to say Lord lead me into an
understanding read the words make time
for it think about what you read and
then say Lord I'm going to put it into
practice that's right amen thank you so
very much brother Daniel it's
encouraging isn't it reading the word of
God and I like that too no charging
issues right or no pop-up ads coming
here correct or reading the paper pages
of the Bible I want to encourage you
today you may be listening to this
program watching the program saying well
I've got a question I have a comment
there are several ways that you can do
that that is Bible QA at
3abn.tv that's 3abn or Bible QA at
3abn.tv you can also text us at
618-228-3975 brother Ryan what I want to
do here is I want to jump down to this
question here this comes from James and
it's a really a heavy heavy question
here all right and it uh says this where
in the Bible does it state that hell is
not Eternal all right all right so
actually there's a lot of scriptures
that seem to make this hell experience
to be Eternal I want to read a few of
those but I also want to highlight a few
things as we read these texts because we
have to again study to show our
self-approved second Timothy chapter 2
verse 15 encourages us to do this that
when we study something don't just
isolate a text pop out a text from
scripture and say oh there's my proof
text it says this word or it says this
phrase so it must be the case sometimes
it can lead us to misinterpret something
unless we we take a survey of scripture
and include a balanced perspective of
what all the texts in the Bible say
about a subject and so I'm going to go
first to Matthew chapter 18 verse 8. and
notice what it's saying here Jesus is
speaking he says if your hand or foot
causes you to sin cut it off and cast it
from you for it is better for you to
enter into life main life or excuse me
life lame or maimed rather than having
two hands or two feet but to be cast
into Everlasting fire so people will
isolate that text they'll say oh there
it is Everlasting fire hell is
Everlasting in the literal sense it just
keeps going on to infinity and beyond
it's ceaseless it never stops but yet
when we look at this we know that this
Everlasting fire it is very much the
same word
Eternal Everlasting we use these words
to interchangeably to describe something
that is never ending or keeps on going
but this Everlasting fire that is
mentioned here of course is referring to
the results of what what happens after
that fire has served its purpose the
results of that fire is Everlasting the
results of what that fire does is
eternal and we're going to see that as
we go through of these other texts so
keep that in mind it does seem like it's
saying that there's this never-ending
fire but does it let's continue on and
read another text Matthew chapter 25
verse 41 again Jesus says then he will
also say to those on his left depart
from me you cursed into
Everlasting fire there it is prepared
for the devil and his angels okay keep
that in mind the devil and his angels
and these will go away into Everlasting
oh punishment oh boy so the Everlasting
fire and everlasting punishment is
synonymous with each other notice how it
doesn't say Everlasting punishing
punishing would communicate something
ongoing and never ending but the Eternal
punishment has there's a definite time
applied to that there's a purpose it
means until it has served its purpose
but it goes against it goes on to say
but righteous into eternal life
um second Thessalonians Thessalonians
chapter 1 verses six through nine I I
I'm quoting this here because it goes on
to say since it is a righteous thing
this is verse six for second
Thessalonians chapter 1 verse 6. it's a
sense it is a righteous thing with God
to repay the tribulation those who
troubled you and to give you who are
troubled rest with us when the Lord
Jesus is revealed from heaven with his
mighty angels and flaming fire taking
Vengeance on those who do not know God
and on those who who do not obey the
gospel of our Lord Jesus Christ these
shall be punished with Everlasting
notice destruction Everlasting what
destruction that means something is
destroyed something is brought to an end
through this fire or through this
Everlasting fire that we're reading
about uh you know Jesus goes on to
describe in the parable of the wheat and
the tares remember the tares represent
the wicked and the wicked are going to
be thrown into the fire but he says this
will occur at the end of the world and
then when you go into Revelation and
study Revelation chapter 20 it's
interesting because we see how far
happening in verse 9 at the end of this
world the devil and his angels remember
we read that earlier in Matthew Matthew
chapter 18 where it says the devil and
his angels will be thrown into fire as
well verse 9 of Revelation 20 says they
went up on the breath of the earth
surrounded the camp of the Saints and
the Beloved City and the fire came down
from God out of heaven and devoured them
I also think of Jew chapter or well Jude
verse 7. it talks about Sodom and
Gomorrah being destroyed with eternal
fire well if the Eternal men to infinity
and beyond and never ending well then we
should be able to go over to where the
Sodom and Gomorrah is today and still
see it have been Flames obviously that's
not the case it means a definite period
of time and the text that really seals
it all up to me for me is Malachi
chapter 4 verses one and three I don't
have time to read it but go read Malachi
chapter 4 verses 1 and 3 where it talks
about how this Earth will burn like an
oven and all of the wicked will be ashes
in other words the results of the fire
is eternal it is Everlasting and of
course but it will serve its purpose and
will come to an individually amen yeah
thank you so much for that answer from
the word of God and thank you for
submitting your question
brother Johnny this comes from Sherry
from Pennsylvania why does it say in
First Corinthians 5 8 to keep the feasts
but we say the feasts are done away with
at the cross biblical references please
thank you very much for the question
first of all if you take a look at this
verse that you mentioned First
Corinthians chapter 5 verse 8 it says
Feast singular
it is not Feast plural and it's talking
about a a specific Feast that is
mentioned there for symbolical purposes
and we're going to take a look at that
in a moment so why do we not keep the
feasts
uh the first thing we'd like to point
out is Colossians chapter 2 verse 13 and
14. it says and you being dead in your
sins and the uncircumcision of your
flesh have to quickened together with
him giving having forgiven you all
trespasses notice it says blotting out
the handwriting of ordinances that was
against us which was contrary to us and
took it out of the way nailing it to his
cross when Jesus Christ dies on the
cross the sacrificial system comes to an
end
this is shown by the veil of the temple
which was torn in two you can let's go
ahead and read Matthew 27 verse 15 and
51 and Jesus cried out again with a loud
voice and yielded up his Spirit then
behold the veil of the temple was torn
into from top to bottom and the
earthquake and the Rocks were split now
why does the bible take you where Jesus
is being crucified suddenly transfers
The Narrative to the temple because the
death of Jesus Christ made the
sacrificial system come to an end that's
why it transfers The Narrative from
Jesus dying on the cross to the temple
saying the temple no longer is used for
sacrificial purposes Christ has died for
us and all of the feasts had sacrificial
sacrifices involved and so Jesus Christ
has died we don't need to do sacrifices
so keeping the feast involves doing
sacrifices there's no Temple Christ that
already died for us these are all things
that help us understand that we do not
have to keep the feasts now let's go to
First Corinthians chapter five beginning
in verse one to see the context of this
and you'll see it's not really talking
about hey let's keep the fees this is
something we have to do this is being
used symbolically First Corinthians 5
beginning in verse one it is actually
reported that there is sexual immorality
among you the King James version says
fornication I'm reading new King James
and it says and sucks such sexual
immorality as it's not even named among
the Gentiles that a man has his father's
wife and you are puffed up and have not
rather mourned that he who has done this
deed might be taken away from among you
for I indeed as absent in body but
present in spirit have already judged as
though I were present uh him who has so
done this deed in the name of our Lord
Jesus Christ
when you are gathered together along
with my spirit with the power of our
Lord Jesus Christ deliver such a one to
Satan for the destruction of the flesh
that his Spirit may be saved in the day
of the Lord Jesus no talk about a feast
up to this point now look at this how
symbolically this is used you're
glorifying is not good do you not know
that A little leaven leavens the whole
lump
therefore Purge out the old leaven that
you may be a new lump since you are
truly unleavened
for indeed Christ Our Passover was
sacrificed for us Christ Our Passover
was sacrificed for us we do not need to
keep the Passover because Christ Our
Passover was sacrificed for us and it
says therefore let us keep the feast now
with the old leaven now with the leaven
of malice and wickedness but with the
unleavened bread of sincerity and Truth
this is being used symbolically to tell
you Christ Our Passover was sacrificed
for us but the Greek words here are used
to to say keep the feast it is
inconsistent to to say this is a command
to literally keep the feast this is
telling us to keep on and keep on
keeping the elements that were involved
in removing leaven the Jews had a
process part of the part of the the
feast that a Passover was putting leaven
throughout the house and having the
children go out and find all the lemon
let's take it out of the house this is
symbolic of sin so this is what I say
let us live keep on putting away a sin
yes my time is up I can't continue but I
think we're giving you something to work
on Amen no praise the Lord great
biblical answer there thank you so much
brother Johnny
this is another question from uh
Trinidad Daniel and it comes from June
can you please explain Romans 7 1
through 3. okay there's a lot to explain
here so in three minutes you need to go
and hit pause here go read Romans 7 1-6
then the whole book of Romans 2. but
Romans 7 is following up on a line of
reasoning Paul began and then uh is
conducted intimately with Romans 6. in
Romans 6 there's two illustrations
should we continue in sin Paul says no
Romans 6 verse 1 because you were
baptized and you're you're man of sin
the sinful nature died so you don't live
in it skipping down to verse 15 of
Romans 6 you are you and when when
you're you're your spiritual nature is
alive you now are slaves to God no
longer slaves to sin it's exclusive and
that brings us into Romans 7 where Paul
says in verse 1 I'm speaking to those
who know the law so he's now going to
give us a picture of how we relate to
the law and here's the picture you the
woman are tied to your first husband
that's your sinful nature and what ties
you to that with a legal agreement it's
the law and this is the law when your
heart is unrepentant it's the law that
even if you obey it it simply makes you
want to rebel because there's no
relationship it's just a Law Without
Love rules without the love of Christ
and so it it actually brings up within
you this rebellion and but when your
your sinful nature dies you immediately
as Paul says or in Romans 7 verse 4 so
that you may be married to another to
him who is raised from the dead and so
you're immediately now married to your
new nature the nature of Christ Christ
and his Perfection and what is it that
holds you to Christ it is the law that
is still there the same law that forbid
adultery before still exists only now
you see it differently because of the
love of Christ instead of being
something external imposed upon you that
you do it or die because you have to it
now is something that is Jeremiah 31
verse 33 says God has written it upon
your heart and it comes from within
because you see the love of God and so
what does the law do it reveals my
sinfulness and as my sinfulness is
revealed my eyes are turned to the Cross
so every time the law reveals my great
need oh it's a blessing that I say thank
the Lord thank goodness once again thank
Jesus for what he's done for me so the
law is still there but now my
relationship to it is different I'm no
longer fighting against it and wouldn't
it be easier to have a Christian Life
that comes from within that comes from
what what God has done for me rather
than saying I have to but now because
God loves me so much that I want to and
so listen to what verse 4 here says it
says
you're married now to another to him who
raised you from the dead that we should
bear fruit to God God right there is the
life of obedience and it's The Obedience
that comes from the heart and thank
Jesus that he has given us the ability
to see the law the way it truly is
amen yeah three minutes think about it
wow it's fast thank you so very much but
there's so much to study so much in the
word of God again thank you for your
questions brother Ryan here this is a
really good question are there really
mansions in heaven or is that figurative
[Laughter]
you know I think we shouldn't be get too
caught up on the word Mansions even
though yes that's a great question I've
often thought many times you know when I
get to Heaven Is there going to be like
this giant mansion when we think of
mansions we look at the this week right
yeah worldly Earthly mansions with
massive you know rooms and massive
living rooms and huge bedrooms and
multiple car garages and you know all
these different things but yet sometimes
we have to look beyond that and
understand what it is Christ is actually
saying it's interesting that he says
here in John chapter 14 verses one
through three which is where we get this
from and I'm just going to read the text
it says let not your heart be troubled
you believe in God believe also in me in
my father's house he says our many name
Mansions if it were not so I would have
told you I go to prepare a place for you
and if I go and prepare a place for you
I will come again and receive you to
myself that where I am there you may be
also that's the key to focus on that
he's going away to prepare a place for
us that where he is there we may be also
isn't that always been God's ultimate
desire I mean it's interesting that he
said in my father's house Jesus just
uses this terminology a couple of times
in the gospels and it's indirect
reference actually to the temple for
instance when he comes in and cleanses
the temple he says you have made my
father's house a den of Thieves they
were violating that special uh residing
place in which the spirit of God was
supposed to dwell remember uh Exodus
chapter 25 verse 8 where he says let
them make me a sanctuary that I may
dwell among you God wants to be with us
he wants to be in our very presence and
so the key to understanding this are
there literal mentions I don't know what
these mentions are going to look like
the Bible does not describe if it's
going to be like what we see here on
Earth but it certainly means in the
original language here it's the word
Monet which simply means a word for
mentions Monet in the Greek which means
dwelling place or residence and it can
mean as the Bible and Bible translators
have translated it as Mansions but in
this case my friends what we ultimately
see is when we get to Revelation chapter
21 what do we see coming from God out of
heaven we see the New Jerusalem Jesus
says I'm going to prepare a place for
you that where I am there you may be
also and it's amazing that I made
mention of the temple being my father's
house when you get to Revelation 21 you
see the New Jerusalem coming down from
God out of Heaven God's people are there
they're dwelling with him and it says
there's no need of a temple because God
and Jesus Christ is the temple they are
why because now they're in his presence
they're dwelling with him so are there
going to be literal like you know MTV
crib mansions in heaven I don't know
we'll have to wait to see but we
certainly know that that means that we
will dwell in the very presence of God
as just as he's always wanted praise the
Lord Glory Hallelujah right looking
forward to that day what we're going to
do right now is take a quick break so
stay with us for some closing comments
if you're enjoying our 3abn Bible q a
then tell your friends each Monday will
bring you a fresh program answering the
Bible questions you send us using God's
holy word to shed light on those texts
that seem difficult to understand to
have your questions answered on a future
program just email them to us at bibleqa
at 3abn.tv that's Bible QA at 3abn.tv
you may also text your questions to
618-228-3975 that's
618-228-3975 be sure to include your
name and where you live and then
watch3abian Bible q a for answers from
God's word
thank you so very much for joining us
for today's Bible q a program it's a
blessing to study the word of God in
closing Pastor John do you have any any
thoughts to end the program with yes uh
concerning the feast you know all of the
feasts were supposed to keep fresh in
the minds of people that Jesus Christ
would come and die for us notice what it
says in Hebrews 10 4 for it is not
possible that the blood of bulls and
goats could take away sins we have the
true sacrifice and that is Jesus we
don't need the feast we don't need to
keep the feast just keep following Jesus
amen how about you Professor Daniel yes
uh for for anybody who is beginning to
study the Bible or continuing there's so
many bits of wisdom and little jewels
from God's word that you can add here
but I just wanted to encourage you to
find an encourager somebody who when you
study the word you can share with them
what you've learned because when God
gives us blessings they're not for us to
hoard they they flow through us two
other people so if you're just starting
to study the word of God find somebody
maybe a family member someone you can
trust and share with them here's what
I've read today here's what I've learned
and here's what it's meant to me that
will help you grow so much amen praise
the Lord Amen brother Ryan uh just keep
in mind the words Everlasting Eternal
and even the word forever that we see
sometimes in the Bible it does mean and
can mean a definite period of time
especially in regards to the destruction
of the wicked and again I reference
Malachi chapter 4 verses one through
three it's speaking of the righteousness
walking out after God has destroyed the
wicked it says you shall trample the
wicked for they shall be ashes Under The
Souls of your feet on the day that I
shall do this saith the Lord so God is
not a horrible horrible God that just
allows people to burn for ceaseless ages
it will serve its purpose and once it
has served its purpose the fires will go
out wow amen amen thank you brother Ryan
brother Daniel brother Johnny thank you
for joining us today thank you for
opening the word of God again at home we
thank you for submitting your questions
and comments to us we want to encourage
he's been mentioned today to study the
word of God in closing I like to always
read second Timothy 2 15 study to show
thyself approved unto God a Workman that
needeth not to be ashamed rightly
dividing the word of Truth God bless you
we'll see you next time
[Music]
foreign